welcome to a very special edition of the
Reuben report and I'm not Reuben I'm
Larry King and I will be interviewing
Dave Rubin welcome to your show
this is wild Larry cos guest hosting my
show from his studio that's very nervous
David is all new to me and it's just a
spine-tingling yeah this must be Barry I
mean you've interviewed everybody but
this has got to be for me pretty much
the tops this is the true who do you say
like Dalai Lama top three Dali
oh no no Dolly's way down dollies down
there I don't know if I crack the top
three basically so give who the top to
pick one from entertain will be Sinatra
alright Sinatra that's respect and one
from the political world seven
presidents all the presidents yeah and
now dave rubin and dave ruel but of the
Reuben rule for you freak it out right
now okay yeah I can't tell you I'm
nervous
well you attend that were you a nerdy
kid who was interested in politics when
he was six years old you know I always
thought that I was right between cool
and nerd I remember around sixth grade
or something thinking that it was gonna
be work to be cool like the cool kids to
be around the cool kids because I never
felt cool and I was okay I was into
science and video games and board games
and all that stuff I played sports too
but I remember thinking it would be very
it would be hard it would be effort to
be with the cool kids all the time
and I knew I would never be at the top
of that thing so I kind of hung out with
the Nerds and and I loved it I literally
I kid you not I did not touch a sip of
alcohol or smoke weed or a cigarette or
anything in high school I was up with my
friends playing video games everybody
drove up I grew up I was born in
Brooklyn
just like my esteemed interviewer and I
grew up in Long Island and lived in
Manhattan for most of my adult life
until I moved to LA four years ago so
I'm a I'm a true coast-to-coast guy
what'd your father do my dad was in or
is in sales for women's clothing he's in
the schmata biz you want a meal when did
you get interested in power
I think probably around seventh-grade I
think it was 1988 was the Dukakis verse
verse George HW Bush and I remember very
we were doing like a mock election in my
social studies class and I remember
George HW Bush had said to Dukakis your
illiberal and Dukakis said I'm no
liberal or something to that effect but
I remember thinking what this doesn't
make any sense to me liberals are the
good guys why why would you be afraid of
saying you're a liberal and that was
really my awakening to sort of being a
liberal which to me meant looking out
for other people it meant caring about
the other and trying to make sure that
we have some sort of cohesive Society
and not being truly racist or bigger
than any of that stuff I think what's
happened to the word liberal especially
in the last couple of years as I talked
about on my show has really changed but
I've always been interested in politics
I was a Poli Sci major so I may be I may
be the only person in America who got a
Poli Sci degree and it's actually using
it for something did you want to get
into the realm of running for office
yeah I did actually at first I thought I
would go into politics and I remember I
was in a politics class I think my
junior year of college I went to SUNY
Binghamton so I came through the state
system and you know didn't have to spend
a ton on college and that's why I'm very
much for you know state-funded education
and I remember being in a class about
public policy and the professor
everything that everyday we'd be in
there he would talk about how nothing
works the way it's supposed to be
nothing the system just doesn't function
the way it is and I kind of remember
thinking this doesn't seem right who
would want to be part of this system and
I think a lot of people feel that way
which is why it's really why we end up
with such corrupt candidates because who
would ever I mean would you ever you
know in your whole lifetime will you
have ever wanted to go through that
machine well the best place and all of
that
Esquire did a great article years ago on
a hundred people who would be great
presidents and you don't know them of
course of course the best of us doesn't
run yeah and it just seems so obvious
now and look you know we can talk about
Trump and Clinton and that whole thing
but it's like we got somebody in office
who uh you know I've been saying I think
this might be good
now I think there's some opportunity I
wonder about his moral center and you
know as I was just saying to you in the
green room I think he's a populist not
an ideologue so maybe there's a way that
the population can actually push him to
do good things as opposed to an
ideologue who really believes something
that could potentially be scary so I
think there's opportunity there but look
what he had to do to become president
you know crooked Hillary and little
Marco and lion Ted and all this stuff
that has nothing to do with politics it
has nothing to do with you know for 50
years that you've been talking to all of
these incredible people
how many issues we'll really discuss
there was build a wall right which now I
think he's backtracking a little on
yeah or you know deport these people now
he's backtracking on some of that stuff
which i think is actually fine but all
of this stuff it's like does it doesn't
feel like we had an election it feels
like we had a popularity contest so you
chose rather than getting into the game
talking about the game asking about the
game yeah looking at the game I think
that well for me and you know I'm
talking to the right guy now I mean that
concept of figuring out why people think
the way they think you know like just
sitting across from somebody and and
really trying to not grill them actually
I'll give you a question here which is
sometimes people will say to me you know
Dave you you do too many softball
interviews and my policy on interviewing
is I want to watch them hang themselves
so I want to learn and I want to get it
the best way I can yeah and the me the
dumbest way to learn is to scream it's a
day or two attack them or to make them
defensive yeah if you want to learn like
someone said if I if someone asked me if
you were going to interview Oh
Saddam Hussein or the guy who bombed
9/11 mm-hmm I were I would have said to
him you will from one of the richest
families in Saudi Arabia yeah why'd you
leave see I want to get at him I also
knew a long time ago that no one evil
thinks they're evil so you don't calm
your hair in the morning Hitler didn't
comb his hair and say I am at
first rate he thought he was doing
pretty great strike so you have to come
at him from the angle until you get to
yeah you know like I would love I used
to interview racists you know like
George Wallace when he was governor
before he changed and I talked about the
pigment of skin one what is it about the
pigment of skin yeah that would cause
you to think differently about a person
yeah why do you why do you buy tanning
lotion right and isn't that much more
interesting than just the the minutiae
of the day-to-day machine you know
that's I think that is what the people
are upset with more than anything else
they're sick of what Cable News has done
to us this fair game news they're
breaking news literally I mean they're
breaking the way news should be
delivered to us and people are tired of
that they're you know this idea of
outrage culture that we're in very much
every morning you wake up and you can
look at Twitter and figure out a
thousand reasons that people are
outraged and then at the end of the day
it's like they're reporting it's like
you've got all these reporters and what
are they doing they're waiting for Trump
to tweet they're just waiting for him to
say something so they can write a piece
about it and they can be outraged and
that's not news and it's also it's not
even good for your brain it's not good
for your ability to do this to just
calmly for however long sit in front of
somebody hear you respond that's what we
need and enjoy it don't you and I've got
to leave your ego at the door I try to I
really try to I mean to me when I when I
have a good interview and the hour
finishes I learned something which is
really great and I would say almost
every week I've learned something maybe
not something good maybe I thought well
you know that guy said something really
crazy and I don't buy that but I've had
I've had interviews I had larry elder on
my show who I'm sure you know Larry oh
and Larry is he's a good illustration
he's well Larry it was when I was doing
my show here a tour and he was in this
very room and he was really pushing that
was talking about systemic racism and he
was really pushing me on it what is
systemic about it he wasn't saying
racism doesn't exist but built into the
system and really pushed me on it and
has changed my views a little bit on how
it works and you know he gets a ton of
crap because he's a
black conservative so he's thought of as
the other and he's treated really
terribly by by a lot of the black
community donating self-hating and he's
an Uncle Tom and all this stuff so all
of him on and then I'll have you know
somebody like Mike Serna [ __ ] who's
thought of as an alright guy and it you
know either way I like having those
conversations it's like how would you
learn if you only listen to people that
you agree with I have no idea any you're
not kidding do you when you see a race
like we just had do you get turned off
from the game man it's it's wild because
this whole last two years it's been
exhilarating for me in a certain way and
even and the fact that I got to know you
in these last year's and bring my show
here and now do it independently so it's
been a good two years for me sort of
professionally and and personally and
all that there are times when it's
exhilarating there are times when you
really feel like you're in something and
you know it's like when you're talking
to people that are actually really
saying something not not the interviews
that happen every now and again where
you know the guest isn't really offering
something they're either promoting
something or they're there they're just
saying more of nothing for publicity
sake right but sometimes you talk to
someone you go wow this is this is an
idea that could actually change people
so it's been exhausting I think
everybody's kind of exhausted right now
we're having this weird time in America
right now where people can't believe it
like it actually it happened the Trump
thing happened I would say I was on Joe
Rogan's show the day before the election
and I said I think this thing's 50/50 I
I really believe that the whole time the
Trump people were excited and the
Hillary people were begrudging ly voting
for or not voting and that's what
happened but it's so it's exciting and
it's also exhausting because I don't
know that this is exactly how politics
is supposed to be you know to me a good
political system would be one that we
don't have to talk about it that often
you know one that it works and because
it works we don't have to think about it
constantly and she won the popular vote
yeah had he won the popular vote and
lost the electoral the word rigged would
be in our culture stemmed into our head
every day now yeah well that's
investigate demand investigations of
course he would he was laying the
groundwork
or that which by the way I called him on
that I said you can't it's possible that
an election could be rigged but you
can't say it's rigged before it happens
with no evidence that's not to say the
DNC didn't do some shady stuff because
they did we know what they did to Bernie
and we know that you know that Donna
Brazile was feeding Hillary questions
and so they did a lot of shady stuff but
that's different than rigging the
election actually changing votes and
that kind of thing but I think everybody
is kind nobody wants this to happen
again what even if Trump has four great
years let's let's go on the best opera
you know the best way this could go
Trump has a great four years the
economy's chugging again he's lowered
taxes we don't get into some extraneous
war or any of that stuff right I think
still no Matt first off I think he's
gonna be a one-term president no matter
what I suspect he'll he'll be 74 by the
time it's over I think he kind of
doesn't even believe that he can't
believe that even one you know you you
know him I mean you know 30 years you've
known over 30 years so I just never
known anyone this well who became
president that's pretty good when you
think about that how many people know if
you grew up with the George Bush oh yeah
you were in Chicago with with Obama and
you knew woman yeah but I know this guy
in your flip phone I know you have your
flip phone anything I don't tree number
things right no I know it's cell phone
yeah they are but I just well been to
dinner with him uh lunch with him we
were fathers of the year together in
1996 in in 2006 in New York their
fathers of the Year dinner yeah he and I
were chosen so for all the people for
all the people that are worried about
his moral Center that's been the big
thing with me is that I I don't think
he's Hitler I don't I think he's an
opportunist I think he's a populist but
for but I just don't know what he
fundamentally believes I don't know you
put anyone at ease at any level on that
because I know he's much more socially
liberal yeah then he was in this
campaign right so that's the irony the
the Republicans have come around to gay
marriage basically putting putting pen
sucide for a second because there's a
real religious piece to that if you
think about it what did Trump do he
became he had Peter teal who's an openly
gay man opened for him at the are
and see and got an applause break Trump
talked about gay rights and they
applauded it and stood up so he's
changed things and what people don't
like is the way he speaks and we have to
kind of combine things that don't make
sense can someone say really gross stuff
you know the stuff about grabbing women
and all that can you say things that
really sound terrible but also at the
same time be doing good and how do we
combine all of those things and that
just shows that we're all complex we've
all done we've all done bad things we've
all said bad things that doesn't mean we
can't do good things so that that's kind
of where we're at I think Trump is a
bizzy's an isolationist I think but yeah
he doesn't you know Ken Kenny basically
can we make money from this which pretty
much should be how the government
operates right that the government isn't
there to make money the government's not
there to make money but if I think if he
can if he just focuses on economics just
helping our basic economic system may be
doing some infrastructure stuff you know
he has to do something relative to
immigration but if he can sort of do
that stuff and we don't have to think
think how sad it is for for gay people
that had to vote Democrat because one
party basically hated them one party
said you will not be treated equally
under the law and many minorities know
about this certainly the black community
knows about this throughout history but
that's a sad place to be so if we can
put that social stuff aside and then
people can vote on the things that
actually government is supposed to do
economy
defense things like that immigration I
think that would be a net win Bill
Clinton ended up despite the problems a
very popular president I am generally
called a successful president trillion
dollar surplus wonderful speaker
ingratiating you cannot not like them
everybody here not everybody yeah how
did she lose she has literally the
reverse of that I've heard that from
many people that have met her privately
that behind the scenes she's she's
that's what everybody says to Yuma I've
heard that for many people I heard that
from somebody a friend of mine who's a
producer on a show that she went on a
couple weeks ago right before the
election behind the cameras she was
great
greenroom great excited engaging knew
everybody's names blah blah blah then
she
in front of camera I think the fakeness
we live in a different time now you know
it's not the time of network television
anymore with everything being
prepackaged and pre-produced and all
that so for example we we talked for
literally two minutes sitting over there
and now we're doing this there's no
expectations you can I said do you ask
me anything you want you said you were
nervous but that you were gonna be
alright but but people are sick of all
this prepackaged nonsense when when she
goes on you know Steve Harvey Show and
I'm sure he's a perfectly lovely guy but
they've already given her the questions
were her team wrote the questions for
him or goes on all these other shows
when she goes on to you know two ferns
with Zach Galifianakis again I'm sure
he's a lovely guy but that doesn't win
you anything people want genuine look I
would have treated an interview with her
I think the way you would have which is
I really would have tried to get to why
why do you want to do this why do you
you Hillary Clinton why do you want to
do this and I think that she missed that
she it came off that she was just part
of the corrupt system people are tired
of the system and the proof is in the
pudding because they voted for Donald
Trump who they don't aren't really sure
what he believes so I think her failure
was that thing that you know a lot of
people talk about when but when you've
interviewed bill would he sat down and
you thought wow there's something
there's something truly transcendent
here I think she just missed that and I
think the fake laughing and the fake
smiling and all that stuff people
weren't feeling it anymore
do you think people will miss the
oratorical skills of Obama yeah as
opposed to Trump because Obama may have
been one of the great artists ever I got
to say I voted for Obama twice and I've
I've been hard on him on certain things
but but basically I think he's been a
good president and we've had eight
pretty good years there's some things
that he did wrong
I think the Syria Red Lion thing was it
was a huge problem not to say we should
be a war there but but when you say
there's a red line if we don't back it
up it core it creates all sorts of
problems not only with our enemies but
our allies suddenly go wait wait wait
the u.s. used to honor its word so he's
made he's made a few errors but it's
basically been a pretty scandal-free
administration you know his speech
the day after the election when he
talked about how we have to have an easy
transfer of power and in a democracy you
don't always get what you want and that
we have to respect the system and the
system wasn't always going to go your
way I thought it was one of his best
moments I thought it was one of his best
moments and I think he's really really
smart and I think as I said before
because Trump's a populist I think Obama
knows if he can build some bridges with
him Obama is gonna be a man of the
people when he's out of this when he's
out of the office and I think he'll be
able to help influence Trump and I think
that could be good so I think we could I
think what could be happening right now
is people realize that the far right has
gone off the deep end they realized that
the far left is gone off the deep end
but if you're a decent liberal if you're
a basic liberal and you're a basic
conservative an old-school conservative
old-school liberal you're not an enemy
with each other anymore
so what you care you know you have a
little bit of a different feeling on
taxes you know the liberal wants it to
be a little higher brother that's a
little lower you have a little
difference on abortion now you may want
even one of you may want it to be
completely illegal in one perfectly
legal but those are all things that
that's what a society is about right
that's what the actual conversation of a
society is about and these people are
not enemies so I think there there
really could be a new center growing but
the big question now is do you worry
about mr. bannon look
Breitbart basically they do news to the
right the way that everyone else is
doing news to the left that that seems
to me to be the basic truth so for a
BuzzFeed or all these other
organizations that do sort of tilted
news to the left they're doing it to the
right and because most news news
organizations are left they feel that
Breitbart is completely out of control
now do they do suspect things sure do
they lead with headlines in a shady way
and do they do clickbait and all the
other stuff that that everybody else is
doing yes so the question is what is ban
and really want people are saying it you
know is he an anti-semite or is he a
white nationalist or any of that stuff I
mean I guess hosted for you for piloting
a couple weeks ago I had the
editor-in-chief of bright butter
Breitbart on this guy Joel Pollak he's
an Orthodox Jew he's wearing a yarmulke
so if that ends a white nationalist and
an anti-semite he has a strange group of
people that he's hired I mean he had
been Shapiro on
on his network as well they're not
they're not in cahoots anymore so my
basic thing would be you have to give it
a chance
I will hold Trump's feet to the fire
absolutely absolutely that's what you're
supposed that's what you supposed to do
as an interviewer as a journalist as a
public person I'll do all that but I
think you have to at least let's see who
he picks let's see what the cabinet all
looks like and let's start seeing what
they do and the second they're doing
something bad you call them out on it
but protesting right now seems like a
protest against the will of the people
mainstream media where is it crumbling
crumbling far and well I'll tell you
this I said this you once before but I
really believe that you leaving CNN has
a lot to do with this there are so few
people out there that people trust but
it's not only about trust that they feel
like they can turn on the television or
turn on YouTube or whatever they're
doing and feel like someone is doing
their best to give you something decent
and maybe something honest and fair I'm
pretty sure you would say that you're
not the perfect person fair to say fair
to say I've heard and right and that's
that I would say the same thing about
myself right we fail every day as as
people but I think what the what the
mainstream media has crumbled with is
that they've put on all of these
partisan people who used to work at
campaigns whose brother works at this
campaign who's in bed with this media
person or they have super-delegates that
are pretending that they're analysts and
all of this stuff and they're all in bed
together and they go to the White House
Correspondents Dinner and while these
are the people that are supposed to be
guarding the estate it's they're
guarding the henhouse and they're
selling the chicken they're selling the
eggs out back I mean that's what they're
doing and everybody knows it so the
reason it's crumbling really though is
because online media which has a slew of
false also I mean I'm an online guy now
you're an online guy now I mean the
online media look it's wild west so any
of us can get in there's no there's no
barrier that's a huge problem because
then anyone says I'm telling you the
truth and congratulations you're equal
to anyone else
so that's a huge problem but that said
you can get more truth so for example
the when Hillary on 9/11 had
the episode where she fainted or passed
out or whatever it was if we hadn't had
online media if that guy that one random
guy hadn't videotaped that thing with
his iPhone
that would have been searly doubt it
would have ever trickled up that way but
you know it was on Twitter and I
remember seeing five minutes later when
someone tweeted at me I saw it's got a
thousand retweets and then next they
know 10,000 30,000 50,000 whatever it
ended up getting and it's like they
can't deny the truth anymore so we're in
a weird spot where I think this election
got them to parody I think mainstream
media and online media were exactly the
same and I think it's about to tilt I
think it's about to tilt in our favor
the other example in our favor is I
wonder how many white cops shot black
people before there was the iPhone yeah
look we are getting information fast
whether it's white cops shooting black
people or black cops shooting back tube
which has been the case of some of these
incidences lately I mean we are getting
information fast there's also a huge
risk in that because you only see
selective things - you know it I mean if
you don't know what if it's a random
person you don't know where they clipped
it you don't know what happened right
before that you don't know what happened
right after that so there's a way we can
all be manipulated but as a general rule
I would be for more information is
better and but again - the trust issue I
think is the most important thing there
is a feeling that and I think this is
what this is what crushed Hillary at the
end this is what kept her people at home
they felt that she was part of the
system connected to the media that just
was not being honest that was mocking
everyone in the middle of the country
that was telling everybody that they're
bigots and racists and homophobes and
all of this stuff and it's simply not
true it's lazy thinking Barack Obama
eight years ago was not for gay marriage
was he a homophobe I really doubt it so
you can't just expect the second you are
okay with change that everyone who
doesn't get on the change train with you
is suddenly a bigot or a racist and I
think this is a huge problem of the left
and that's why right now I say often
that defending my liberal principles
right now is becoming a conservative
position that's a scary place for a
liberal so where's where's what's the
future what's five years media going to
look like the mainstream media is
crumbling fast I mean it's really
crumbling fast so I think that the
those are the cable networks the cable
networks are crumbling but look they
have a lot of money behind them so
they'll adapt and they should adapt I
you need something mainstream you need
we can't just all cater our news to each
other to ourselves basically it's a huge
problem you know we've talked about this
before that you know if you're just
walking around and you only select if
you're a right-winger and you only
listen to right-wing things you're a
left wing or left wing things guess what
that's fertile ground to start killing
people because you'll you'll assume that
you're so right and morally right all
the time so I think they're going to
start crumbling the crumbling is already
begun the question is how does the
online media replace them does it all
morph into one thing I don't know what
the answer to that is but we need better
people in the game we need better P if
there were a hundred of people doing
better interviews than me I would
consider this a win and I'll find
something else to do I don't I'm not
really good at much else but I would
have been in a basketball player I'm 40
years old with a bad knee yeah you see
in a third party possible I hope so
you know you the same day you
interviewed Gary Johnson a couple months
back I would had him on my show and I
chatted well while you were interviewing
someone prior I was chatting with him in
the green room totally lovely guy really
decent fella I thought this is a guy I
could smoke a joint with I could go
skiing with have a nice time with he
really I think he's a really decent guy
he failed miserably this campaign you
know libertarianism the idea of small
government lower taxes not being
involved in Foreign Wars but having a
strong defense so that you don't have to
go to war I think these are really
simple principles not caring if someone
sleeps with a man or a woman not caring
what they smoke in the privacy of their
own home these are basic simple
libertarian classic liberal ideas that
make so much sense
he had such a great opportunity for all
the people that thought Hillary was
corrupt for the people that thought
Trump was a narcissist he had a great
opportunity to say hey Here I am this is
what libertarianism is about this is
what Liberty what individual liberty
that the government should get out of
your way and and you as an individual
have autonomy over your life what a
great opportunity that would have been
and instead unfortunately I think he was
kind of willfully unprepared I think he
stammered and
humbled a lot and by the way I'll give
him a little out on this which is he's a
decent guy and trying to get a decent
guy through this crappy system you know
it's like putting a putting something
good into like a meat masher well guess
what it's going to look like crap on the
other side why are we a two-party system
we shouldn't be I mean we I think it
worked for a certain amount of time it
look we've done America is still I
believe the greatest country on Earth I
do believe in American exceptionalism
because everybody wants to come here
everyone your what generation immigrant
are you your family we're your parents
first generation um first your first
generation so I'm third I'm fourth
generation I think on both sides
everyone my great-grandparents came here
with nothing then my grandparents owned
a little store my dad made it into
middle class allowed me the
opportunities to do what I do right now
this is the same story that everyone has
unless your ancestors were brought here
as slaves or you were a Native American
and there's a lot to do in those
communities to repair the damage that
was done but everybody wants to come
here we we still people are still trying
to get in they're not trying to leave
cannabis not building a wall to keep us
out even though Lena Dunham and all
these other celebrity said they were
going to leave guess what nobody's
leaving because it's still pretty great
here we have to get out of this
two-party thing though the idea that the
political debate is between Republicans
and Democrats and that's it but there's
nothing out here it's actually it's
actually absurd Franklin Delano
Roosevelt addressed the Daughters of the
American Revolution once and they had
denied a black opera singer from singing
there because she was not a daughter
with the American Revolution he had us
go back to the work revolution and
Franklin Roosevelt spoke the next night
and began by saying my fellow immigrants
because we are all immigrants yeah the
only all right well winding it up what's
next for Ruben what's Reax for Ruben
well we just got to keep building it we
got to keep building it and you know I
didn't I wasn't ever even when I started
a Torah when you kind of said well at
this guy in here I wasn't even planning
on doing an interview show exactly I did
my first interview with Sam Harris and I
thought I used to do a little more newsy
stuff and you know
the view kind of chat stuff and and I
did this interview with with Sam and I
thought wow that really getting into it
with somebody this that's what I love
that's what I want to do and the fact
that you know this Larry King guy said
you're alright at this you never gave me
suspenders though I really thought I
thought there was going to be a pair of
suspenders here but my own niche 5 I got
it well you don't want to what kind of
where I'm wearing but but the point is
but I want it I want to expand what I'm
doing I want people to understand that
you don't have to agree with everybody
you don't have to and you don't have to
just because you don't agree with them
doesn't mean you have to hate them too
but get around the table you know all
these people this year that we're saying
you know I'm not friends with someone on
Facebook anymore I can't talk to my
cousin anymore my brother and I don't
talk politics it's like that's the
symptom of a broken system because
politics you have to be able to talk
about politics with the people you love
and your friends because that's how you
make a better society don't make a
better society by yelling at everybody
and that's why I'm always honored to sit
across the table from you my guest has
been Dave Rubin the host of the Rubin
report on this edition of the Rubin
report which I was happy to sit in for
him next week he'll be back interviewing
either the Rubin doing Rubin or I just
retire right now we'll see and I will
have the answer to the curb and we'll
have the answers the question when cable
networks put up breaking news and they
get actual breaking news how do they
break in to breaking
you